i'm talking with alexander bard at the
ftth conference in
london alexander you've just given us a
fascinating insight into the future of
the internet
give us some of the highlights i think
you were saying it's really in its
infancy
it really is in its infancy and the
internet i believe is one of the biggest
revolutions ever
possibly even the biggest of all and
we've only just started to see the
effects of what happens when seven
billion people
and hundreds of billions of things are
being interconnected with each other
and and who you know what defines the
winners and the losers in the internet
world
i think the quicker you get on the
target the better off you are
so that means if you can expand
broadband and if you can make the
broadband faster
and and stronger and more reliable the
better off you are
and we can already see patterns here so
we can empirically prove that this is
correct
because we've had the internet out for
20 years what we considered broadband
maybe 10 years ago would be something
really lousy today
but if you compare we see that the
countries that did invest in
internet broadband in the 1990s now reap
the benefits because they have more
internet startups
they have more of the new economy and
they have more economic growth than
other countries do
and do you think capacity is always
going to be an issue then because as you
say if what we thought was good
broadband a few years ago is now seen as
you know pathetically small
the demand is insatiable isn't it oh
yeah the demand grows all the time the
thing is that we human beings are
extremely innovative
so when we get access to something we
have a new wonderful tool in our hands
we start to innovate
so we cannot really predict what we're
going to do with the internet over say
10
15 years time we want exception we're
going to do a lot more things with it
so the trick here is to understand that
even if decision makers today are an
older generation it's for the new
younger generation we make the decisions
and that's why i think it's so essential
to give priority to fast and reliable
broadband
and here fiber is key because fiber is
the only technology that we can expand
within the technology
we don't actually have to tear down
london again and again again to
implement new technologies if we invest
in fiber
because fiber in itself is something we
can make a lot faster a lot more
reliable
and we can also push more gigabytes
through the fiber as
as it grows older yeah so when you touch
there on the different generations
but we are finding now users from the
youngest to the oldest aren't we
oh users everywhere my 78 year old mom
is proud that she got spotify at home so
she could
throw away all her cds and she got some
stuffed african monkeys in her living
room instead
and when you think about it stuffed
african monk is a lot more exciting to
look at than boring plastic cds
and the thing is even the hard drive is
dead now you don't need a hard drive
anymore because everything's out there
in the cloud
and so things are moving so fast but
as it's moving faster and faster it's
also becoming easier and easier to use
so for old people too the internet is
becoming more and more user-friendly
the only problem is that the models we
use to understand this phenomena are old
models
we take concepts from the 19th century
and then we applied them to
new technologies i think this is all
going to be the same all over again but
what we need to do is to learn our
lesson from the new technology
it's like the internet wants to
communicate to us
how the internet wants to operate to
make our lives easier and better
and if we listen to the internet instead
of using old models we'd be much better
off
okay alexander well thanks for speaking
to us thank you so much for having me
so the internet we've only just begun
you